foreign
let's go to Diane and one of my favorite
cities in America Santa Fe New Mexico
what's up Diane
hi Dr deloni how are you today so good
how are you
doing good thank you so much of course
what's up
hi
um just a little bit of background
um I'm a disabled veteran I participated
in Desert Storm
and I'm going to be 58 in a few days I'm
a fiscal year baby
and in May I graduated with dual
master's degrees I have an MSW and an
MBA from a State University okay
um the kicker is that two weeks before
graduation my new VA doctor told me that
I had been diagnosed with ADHD but I was
never notified totally fell through the
cracks
because why not right way to go VA way
to go
you have this I'm like oh great
my University was extremely difficult
but I got through
um I also have generalized anxiety
disorder I believed as part of the ADHD
as well
um I was always blue and pink color in
the past I always worked factory jobs
and office jobs I always had trouble
with jobs and with taking care of my
personal affairs so I have a patchy life
of great success and spectacular failure
both
and
now I'm a white collar professional for
the first time in my life and I'm
getting ready for a new job in two weeks
I'm terrified to go into a new
professional job and mess up because of
the ADHD impulsiveness lack of social
skills No Boundaries no sense of time
procrastination all of those classic
symptoms
um I did just start Ritalin with the
help of my new VA doctor she's wonderful
I'm on a waiting list for therapy
how do I make this new transition a
success for my new team for the people
I'm going to be caring for and for
myself awesome awesome question
I think you're awesome by the way Diane
thank you I think you are too well I'm
I'm a YouTuber let's be honest I'm not
that good like I want Tick Tock for
God's sake uh uh you
the people you sit down to love
are so blessed because you're in their
life
I'm glad you've made this transition
um have you heard me talk about my mom's
story
no I haven't okay I'll do this in 30
seconds and we'll get to your answers
but here's some encouragement for you uh
my mom didn't go to Kyle uh just for a
number of reasons
um didn't go to college First Community
College class was age 42.
she graduated her PhD at 57 so y'all are
basically the same boat
wow at 62 63 she got tenured as a
professor at some fancy University and
she's in her 70s and she just I was
talking to her the other night and she's
like yeah I'm going to be teaching at
Oxford next summer
dude this is a lady that would not get
on an airplane minus nine Xanax and now
she's flying all over the world in her
70s teaching it fancy see what I'm
saying so here's what I want to
encourage you the party's just getting
going Diane
that's wonderful to hear the party's
just getting too late no no you got no
all right here's what you've got to do
you've got to cool it with the labels
okay
dunskis no more Blue Collar White Collar
I'm of this not of that here's the deal
you've had ADHD your whole life you
didn't just get it two weeks before you
graduated
you you're right you rattled off a
series of symptoms that fell into a
diagnostic category
and somebody went Wham and stamped your
chart with a stamp
you've been dealing with this your whole
sting in life
um that's true I was diagnosed a second
grader in the early 70s but back then
they thought children outgrew it so
after sixth grade they just cut you off
that was it that's right so you've been
wrestling with this forever did you get
dishonorably discharged
no I'm honorably discharged in fact I
earned an Army Commendation Medal I was
an expert on the M16 I have other
rewards um
hold on you are able to take apart fix
put back together and fire an M16 with
extraordinary Precision correct
um yes I was very good at it you're able
to follow directions in a way when you
are actually engaged in a task in a way
that is second to none very few people
on the planet
can laser in with that ability and focus
on that particular task like you can
true or false
um that's true that's true
so I don't want to hear any nonsense
about your brain is broken
that you have a label that you've got
some sort of dysfunction
okay you do have regulation issues and
as a card carrying member of the how do
you stay employed ADHD Club I would like
to welcome you to Our Gang officially
okay
so
um you are putting a lot of bricks in
your own backpack for no reason other
than the fact that you have been told
throughout your life as much of a as
many of us in America have been told
that there is a difference between
people who
turn wrenches for a living and people
who
write briefs in a lot in a courtroom for
a living and people who do quote unquote
work where they have to tuck their
shirts in and iron their clothes for a
living
there is no difference there is work and
it all has value
um yes you're right
um my father was blue collar
[Music]
um I grew up in a blue collar type of
atmosphere uh learned a lot under him
um but I did too but you also learned
we actually we do the real work around
here those white collar folks they just
that's what you learned my dad was a cop
I did too I learned that too
right like those guys just sit in those
places with their suits on and then when
I got a suit on I was like those guys
work hard
it's a different kind of work they just
they have more access to that more to
better alcohol to numb it all with but
like that job's hard too so what you're
gonna find is as as a as a MSW an NBA as
a leader
leadership's hard
like dealing with the struggles of
people's hard balancing all the budgets
across all that's hard
and so there's not a difference there
this new position
um it'll be my um first um is with the
Adult Protective Services I'm going to
be an investigative caseworker wonderful
so here's what you're going to be really
good at I'm guessing you are going to be
incredible at connecting with your staff
you are going to be the most loved
supervisor you're going to be incredible
showing up on a scene and sitting down
with somebody who or a family that has
to make a hard decision about
putting one of their uh elderly family
members in a home or in a place or
getting you're going to be amazing at
that and you are going to be a nightmare
at case notes
is that true
that's true you're gonna have like
Little Bits of Paper or like a yellow
pad and then you're gonna go from yellow
pad to an iPad and from an iPad to like
a special Journal
it's that's going to be the hard part
right is the is the the businessy parts
making sure your reports are done and
they're written up so that when you go
to court which you inevitably will you
can look like you're an adult right you
see what I'm saying that's gonna be the
hard part is that fair
um yes
um I'm one of those um I'll
procrastinate on something until the
last second to build up the adrenaline
to get it done
um and I have really a terrible time
with a sense of time
that my my wife my wife calls it my
magic time
that's cute she says you're the only
person I've ever met who gets in the
shower at 804 and gets out of the shower
at 8 15 and they're really mad
that they're going to be late to the
eight o'clock meeting
that's 30 minutes away like she's like I
don't know like you have the strangest
it's 7 58 and I'm like no that's cool
there's not an eight there I got time to
shower brush my teeth and shave and sing
a few songs and then drive to work I'll
get coffee too on the way stop the dry
cleaner and then I get to work and it's
8 40. and I'm mad at the time like I'm
like the clock screwed me somehow I I
dude I am with you I am with you
and you're so glad you understand oh god
dude it's it's like uh I was with um I
was with James child the former producer
we're having that uh we're having dinner
the other day together
and we were talking about something and
we had somewhere to be and I just kept
talking and talking and it was like the
light bulb went on for him and he looked
at me and goes you literally experienced
time differently than I do and I was
like I think so anyway because I could
feel it in his body he was like we gotta
go we gotta go and I was like dude we're
in the middle of a hard conversation
let's just keep talking this is great
and that's when he realized oh you are
feeling this whole thing different than
me it just is so here's our
responsibility
I can't be late all the time
because it's disrespectful to people
that I care about and that I love and
who are other professionals
and so
I have to do the best I can to either
hire somebody who keeps me accountable
if I can do that in my current job
I have to create systems that I never
deviate from regardless of quote unquote
and here's what's bad about ADHD folks
how we feel
because we feel so heavy we feel so
strongly about things
yeah so I will exercise regardless of
how I feel unless I'm at a point of
fatigue where I I can cross a line and
now I've been doing it long enough now I
know I literally didn't work out this
morning because I've reached a fatigue
level that if I work out I'm gonna get
sick and then I'm gonna be out for three
days I know that about myself and so I
took this morning off I'll get it in
this afternoon but I took this morning
off that's okay but 99 of the time my
feelings don't get a vote in the
mornings
I will I will do this at this time I'll
do this and I've had to practice it
practice practice practice practice
if you filter your practices through I
have this thing
it's never gonna work
okay okay keep this phrase in your mind
it's a context not an excuse
I like that okay you are going to be
more chaotic and you are going to be
more loving when you get there than
anybody else
you're going to struggle with deadlines
and your reports are going to be better
than anybody's else's
okay so you're bringing a lot to the
table too
um your mission in life is not to not be
so uh ADHD your mission in life is to
get things in on time we're going to
focus on the thing not the label
we're going to do a we're going to do a
awesome job whether we are reassembling
an M16
or whether we are writing case notes
at the at the nursing home
because we just do excellent work that's
just who we are
not absolutely does that make sense
it makes perfect sense and I'm so so
glad you put it that way
um really
um I'll be honest that
um being told that just two weeks before
graduation and then of course you have
all of the emotions and nostalgia in
your life of wow I finally made it and
this is going on
um but then I had that then I had this
inertia for a while I was too afraid to
look for a job
um because I didn't know so there was a
lot of that going on as well but I
finally decided I haven't worked since
January and I said I really really need
to get going on this I've just got to
stop being afraid I have noticed the
difference with the Ritalin which I'm
really glad for oh dude ritalin's in
yeah ritalin's an amplifier
here's the thing here's the demon of
Ritalin it works
it works same as cocaine cocaine works
it works great and then it kills you
right alcohol you're sad alcohol shuts
that thing off it helps you forget and
then it takes everything else with you
with it right so riddle like uh I'm not
gonna be somebody who tells a 58 year
old who's entering into a new job who's
had a lifelong war with ADHD to not take
um medicine I'm not gonna do that that's
cruel okay if you find some relief from
Ritalin which you will I can't imagine a
scenario where you won't
um where you will find some relief good
in that relief
I want you to begin to practice setting
up
um
systems
as the great James Clear says we fall to
the strength of our systems
meaning
if I wake up every day hoping I feel
like exercising I'm never going to do it
but if I've built my morning routine
around 45 minutes of being in my
personal gym and I've over the last
three years I've bought some equipment
in my personal gym the system of my home
is John's downstairs from 5 15 to 6
o'clock AM
then even no matter what I feel I'm
going to fall to my system my kids will
ask me I thought you were working out my
wife would be like what are you doing up
here this is when you exercise like the
whole system is designed for me to work
out during that time we will fall to
those systems so while the the voices
are quieter I had one buddy tell me
who's an adult who started taking
Ritalin things about 50. he said it was
like he didn't realize he'd been
trying to learn and have conversations
in a stadium full of people his entire
life
and then he said it finally sounded like
everyone stopped talking for the first
time in his life
and he was like oh wow that's that's
what he described it as okay
and
I think the last numbers I heard I'm
gonna be off here a little bit but 3 4
75 percent of college age students are
taking some sort of stimulant
that's insane oh wow okay so it's
there's an abuse side of this too here's
what I want you to do I want you to look
at this as the adjunct that it is not
the savior
okay okay it's an outstanding support
especially for someone in your situation
to be able to finally okay everybody
stop yelling wow now I can do the work
is that cool
that's cool
um one good thing about the VA they're
extremely strict with Controlled
Substances that's right that's right
um so I do have to take your analysis
test
um blood work make sure that I'm doing
fine I have to ask for it every month
it's not automatically refilled right
um I have to go in three months for
assessments constantly so it's not just
like oh I'm just getting it and doing
what I want oh yeah yeah absolutely not
you know what like from what you're
telling me and again I'm not a
psychiatrist a psychologist anything I I
it makes sense it makes total sense and
if you were my mom I'd high five you I
wouldn't think I would be like I don't
know am I like good for you okay
um
I am of all the things you've told me
the thing I'm most concerned for you
is you have lived your entire life
trying to chase down the right label for
you
and listen to me so carefully you don't
need a freaking label to tell you that
you're incredible
and nobody's ever told you that Diane
um
I have been told that I've had a hard
time believing it okay
I stand corrected you've not believed it
it's time you're not your anxiety you're
not your ADHD you're not your honorable
discharge you're not your veteran status
those are things you've experienced
those are things you have done those are
parts of your life you are dying
my friend from Santa Fe New Mexico
who's entering into yet another rad
Adventure
being a leader in a job that serves the
least of these in our communities and
struggling families and a bunch of new
professionals and you are selected to
enter into that world
because you're good at it
you're worthy of being loved my sister
regardless of the labels
stay on track with your doctor stay on
track with your counselor good for you
good for you good for you I'm proud of
you
White Collar Blue Collar whatever it is
worked to be excellent and remember it's
a context not an excuse
you still gotta get that work done Diane
we'll be rooting for you